foreign
the hair of his head like the pure wool
the throne was like a fiery flame in his
wheels as burning fire a fiery stream
issued and came forth from before him
thousand thousands ministered unto him
and Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand kid
before him
the Judgment was set and the books were
opened
welcome to q a with elder Randy skeet on
the word inspired my name is Denise
mccurtchen your host and today we are
discussing the books of Heaven
let's have a word of prayer Heavenly
Father we thank you for the Blessed
privilege to delve into your word to
taste and see of your goodness and even
to place our minds on Heavenly things in
a special way oh God purges and cleanse
us and especially be with your man's
servant Elder random ski put your word
in his mouth vivify him with your Holy
Spirit oh God and I pray that we all
will lead here enlightened and empowered
to live better for you and to share this
Gospel of the Canaan
may your name be praised when Jesus is
born amen amen
our special guest is part of the word
inspired family he is a kind and loving
man of God who is wrapped in the arms of
Jesus he travels all over the world
spreading the Everlasting gospel in fact
as we speak he is right now I believe in
Oregon did I get the state correct Ohio
Ohio there we go Ohio Ohio
and he there is doing a weekend Revival
that he has taken the time out to skip
lunch to be with us this afternoon
we have studied for the ministry and he
always keeps the breath with what's
going on in the world and even
um is
suit in terms of History Biblical
history and history in general
and I am humbly honored to welcome the
one and only Elder Randy C we are so
blessed to have you on this channel on
this ski we are grateful that you do the
honor to be here with us
thank you very much my lovely sister God
bless you I always say it's a privilege
for me to be a part of your program I
really respect it very highly I believe
it is of god I truly do and so it is no
inconvenience at all for me wherever I
go to take time to associate and to
participate in this very very blessed uh
outreach program and so thank you and
thank God
amen thank you so much holistic well I'm
not going to delay we will get into our
first question
uh which here is the three is a series
of three what are the books of Heaven
are they bound pages
what is the composition what is the
purpose of each book all right the books
of Heaven you ask what are they and are
they bound Pages I'll take the bound
Pages first we open files on uh
online without turning pages but we
assume returning Pages we turn pages
online but Pages don't really turn
physically and so we need not understand
fully whether the books have Pages as we
know Pages within with God and God does
things differently from the way we do
but we do know from the Bible there are
books in heaven and there are books of
record books of let's go to Genesis
chapter three let's try to get some
understanding as to why God we need
books of record in Genesis 3 when God
came down to the Garden verse 9 and the
Lord God have you found Genesis 3 my
dear sister
Converse line
and the Lord God called unto Adam and
said unto him where are thou and he said
I heard thy folks in the garden and I
was afraid because I was naked and I hid
myself and he said who told you that
thou was naked hast thou eaten of the
tree whereof I commanded thee that thou
should not eat and the man said the
woman whom thou gave us to be with me
she gave me everything I did it now Adam
in that statement blamed God
Eve similarly blames somebody else now
the Bible opens with a human being
blaming God
a human being blaming God in the very
next chapter Cain accuses God saying my
punishment is greater than I can bear he
accuses God of over punishing so it
seems to me no uh surprise that God has
a system that makes it impossible for
him to uh be falsely accused and have
that charge stick also God different
from all of the Gods is the one who
invites us to prove him to test him if
God with confidence invites us to test
him he has to be certain that he has all
the necessary information that he will
win the case that we may bring against
him and so God has books of record now
there's several books you notice in
Revelation 7 not Revelation Daniel 7
verse 10 the Judgment was set and the
books were opened but let's get some
information about the books let us go to
Exodus 32 with read 31 to 33 Exodus 32
31-33 anyone can read but if you want me
to read I can do that Exodus 32 31 to 33
and Moses returned and said unto the
Lord all these people have sinned a
great sin and have made them gods of
gold yet now if thou will forgive this
sin and if not block me I pray thee out
of thy book which thou has written and
so the books are written by God he is
the source he is the author of those
books he is the chronicler of the
information in those books and the law
student Moses verse 33 whosoever have
sinned against me him were like blood
out of my book now Moses says block me
out of your book he does not say books
God said whosoever have sinned against
me him will I blood out of my book and
God goes along with Moses and he says
book but the Bible tells us in Daniel 7
verse 10 there are books so let's go to
Revelation chapter 20 and take a look at
these books Revelation 28 we'll read
verse 12. all right okay
and I saw the dead small and great stand
before God
we're open oh let's pause right there
and the books were open gone
and another book was open so we have
books and we have book the books were
open Daniel 7 verse 10 the books were
open now we have a book we saw a book
with Moses talking to God now we see a
book in Revelation and the Jed the dead
were judged after those things written
where
in the book
written where
in the book or the books are in the
books the dead were judged out of those
things now in other words the the the
the evidence God needs to condemn or to
uh someone to Eternal that that nation
is written in the books
not in the book but what is the book we
know judgment is based on what is in the
books what is in the book now let us go
to
um uh Revelation three let's read verse
five as we get some biblical Clues to
help us solve this mystery which is not
really a mystery Revelation 3 let's read
verse 5.
and I will not plot out his name out of
the book of life right so it's the book
you see the book is The Book of Life all
the other books are books that contain
different kinds of information let us go
to Psalm 139 we read 15 and 16. Psalm
139 15 and the 16.
my substance was not hit from thee and I
was made
made seriously rocked in the lowest part
of the earth listen to 16. thine eyes
did be my substance yet being unperfect
and in thy book yes all my members were
written now there's a book now that
contains our physiological details
are you with me remember Jesus said in
Matthew 10 30 go to Matthew 10 30.
Matthew 10 30.
but the very hairs of your head
phone number and where is that where is
that uh that number kept it is kept in
the book because we know from Psalm 139
16 the members the physical parts of the
body are recorded in a book
the number of follicles on your skull is
recorded in a book now go to Malachi
chapter 3.
Malachi the last book of the Old
Testament brother Malachi we read verse
16 of chapter 3.
then they that fear the lord speak often
one to another and the Lord Harkins
It Was Written okay so now we have a
book that records events in our lives
events so we have a book that records
events we have a book that records
anatomical details we have a book that
records names of those who have served
God and Jesus said if you sin against me
I'll go to out of the book that tells us
clearly that inclusion in that book is
based on a relationship with Christ and
a life of sin qualifies a person to be
removed from that book now let's go back
to revelation 22.
we'll read 12 to 14.
and behold I promise not revelation 22
my mistake Revelation 20. okay yes 12 to
14. and I saw the dead small and great
stand before God and the books were open
and another book was opened well of
course now when you read I saw the dead
small and great stand before God they're
not literally physically standing for
God because the dead know nothing are
you with me they are represented by the
lies they have led and those lives are
meticulously documented in the books of
God
and so the dead do not need their books
they appear almost the books are proxy
for the dead the book which contain
every detail of their life every
anatomical feature every tear every
smile God records Elevate rights steps
to Christ base 85 paragraph four no
tears the shed that God does not notice
there is no smile that he does not Mark
he keeps a record of our Smiles our
tears Psalm 56 verse 8 go there with us
uh the nation Psalm 56 verse 8. see how
detailed God is no one consider God
you're wrong God has a microscopic
record of everything we've done and said
Psalm 56 verse 8 what does that say thou
tell us all my wandering the word tells
me to come to count you know how many
times I wondered running from Saul Now
tell us my wonderings uh-huh but thou my
tears and thy into thy battle uh-huh are
they not in my book no so there's a
written account of how many tears allow
me to smile but you see this is uh
almost incredible to us because that's
not the way we are God is detailed
and so every tier you shed God keeps a
record of that he notices every smile
because in the Judgment he must come out
as absolutely right and those who will
be lost absolutely wrong they cannot be
one microscopic question about the
justice of God when it is all over
that's why every initial bow and every
tongue confess that Jesus Christ is Lord
to the glory of God the Father this is a
long response to your question so there
are books go to Revelation 13 let's read
verse 8.
and all that dwell up in the Earth
shall worship Him
whose names have I written I was muted
whose names are not written in the Book
of Life of the Lamb swaying from the
foundation of the world ah now it's
called the Lamb's Book of Life because
the end of that book you must have
confessed some relationship with Christ
no one can be saved apart from the blood
of Christ so it's the Lamb's Book of
Life those who have put their trust in
Christ at some point even though they
may never have heard the name Christ you
understand what I'm trying to say all
right now so we have the book The Book
of Life where names are recorded who
have a relationship with Christ then we
have the books that record your
anatomical teachers we have book of
remembrance historical events we have
all kinds we mean we don't know how many
books God has but he has books
so the word books can be from two to two
thousand or two million two trillion he
has books all right does that answer the
first question absolutely
God recalls the details God is the
inventor they arranged the librarian the
custodian of all the details in those
books and his judgment is based on what
is in the books now the books have to be
open in other words those who are judged
must understand what the books have you
see they're not close books they are
open now God doesn't need a book open to
none so it is not God who needs No
Angels need to know because Angels don't
know everything you understand there
were some angels who thought Lucifer had
been badly triggered up to the
crucifixion of Christ there were Angels
who were sympathetic Lucifer so Angels
need to understand the unfollen worlds
need to understand and surely we need to
understand so the books are open but God
does not need a book open God knows
what's in the heart all right next
question amen perfect segue the next
question reference to Daniel chapter 7
verses 9 through 10. talking about the
books being opened when were these books
open
now the Judgment began in 1844 October
22. that's when the books were opened
for the beginning of the Judgment that's
what Daniel sees in Daniel 7 the books
were open that's and that's when uh this
uh the order of the books take place
October 24th October 22 1844 the
investigative judgment or the pre-advert
judgment is called that's when the books
were open and that's based on the they
have atonement typology found in
Leviticus chapter 16. that's when the
books were open that's when the Judgment
began the Judgment of the Dead first
then the judgment will pass to the
living and there's no date for that by
the way so we live Faithfully day by day
there is no date for when the judgment
will pass to the living
so this judgment has been going on
since 1844
and Jesus says in Revelation 3 5 he
don't overcometh I will not blunt out
his name God told Moses in Exodus 32 33
whoever sins against me I will block him
out and so what removes the name is the
life of sin
which means the name enters through a
confession of faith in Christ at some
point in one's life
now God examines that confession of
faith has it born fruit the answer is no
the name is removed
and that judgment has a final
determination
once the name is removed the case is
closed this investigative judgment is a
very Solomon serious thing
go to uh
Luke 20 read from verse 34 of Luke 20.
from verse 34 yes okay
and Jesus answering said unto them the
children of this world marry and are
given in marriage yes but they which
shall be accounted worthy to us right
there now oh yeah that's a judgment
statement those this shall be accounted
when are they accounted worthy or when
are they judged to be worthy of eternal
life that's the Judgment we're talking
about
keep reading
two episodes
to obtain that world and the
resurrection from the dead neither marry
nor are given in marriage neither can
they die anymore but they are equal unto
the angels and are the children of God
in the children of the Resurrection okay
and so at some point those who shall be
accounted worthy that is a judgment
statement
now go to First Corinthians 15 let's
read from verse 51.
ah yes
behold I show you a mystery he shall not
all
fleeves
to be alive when Jesus comes that's what
he means keep reading but we shall all
be changed the moment in the twinkling
of an eye at the last Trump the trumpet
shot down and the debts shall be raised
Incorruptible
okay the dead shall be raised what
Incorruptible with eternal life never to
die again but when was the decision made
that this should come up Incorruptible
you understand me a decision because
they can't make it I can't save myself
someone had to have made a prior
determination that man in that grave
will come up Incorruptible that is
what's going on now the judge
and in the Judgment there are books go
to Luke chapter 10 read from verse 17.
Luke chapter 10 verse 17. now just to
set it up in that chapter Christ sent
out 70 disciples to preach now they
weren't the ones who followed him around
he had 12 that were always with him he
had 70 more he sent them out they came
back with a report pick it up from verse
17. and the 17 returned again with Joy
saying Lord even the devils are subjects
unto us through thy name they were
bragging go on
and he said unto them I be helped Satan
as lightning fall from Heaven because
Satan got proud and he was thrown out
he's telling them don't be proud don't
be puffed up because you cast out demons
be careful go on
behold I give unto you power to tread on
serpents and Philippians and over all
the power of the enemy and it was right
there let me digress pause we need to
focus on this verse those of us who are
afraid of the devil and we think where
the world is against us behold I give
you power to tread on serpents and
scorpions and over all the power of the
enemy
we need to fix that in our minds or for
all the power of the enemy who is the
enemy sake Jesus said I've given you but
he says that to his disciples what does
the disciples someone follows Christ an
obedient child of God is guaranteed all
power over all the power of Satan
Satan doesn't want us to know that he
wants us always terrified keep reading
and nothing shall by any means hurt you
go on yes knock up standing in this
Rejoice not that's
the spirits that the spirits are subject
unto you
yes but rather rejoy because your name
are written in heaven yes in our the
book the word book isn't there but we
have to include the word book your names
are written
in a book in heaven
Christ says Rejoice now go to
Philippians chapter 4.
in this chapter there's a conflict
between two women in the church they are
influential women they assisted Paul in
his evangelism and Paul would not take
just any person whether male or female
they must have been capable skillful
women now let's read for verse one
therefore my brethren dearly beloved and
loved for my joy and Crown
Stand Fast in the Lord my dearly beloved
I beseech fee uh-huh
because those two women had a conflict
keep reading
and I intrigued thee also true your
fellow fellow old women yes labored with
me in the gospel yes
and with other my fellow laborers
whose name are written excuse me the
Book of Life yes
the children of God they named The Book
of Life but that name can be removed
by reverting to sin not a mistake a life
of sin these two women whatever they
were doing was not right that's why Paul
said please get it together and he
appeals to Clement help them but their
names were still in the book of life
because an occasional fall does not
disqualify you from the bosom of Christ
it is a life of sin but their names were
in The Book of Life Paul says
the seven of the disciples Christ says
Rejoice because your names are written
in heaven the point we're trying to make
God has a system of recording events all
details that is absolutely flawless
and based on what's written Noah can
finally charge god with Injustice
because he'd provide or even Earthly
trials run by Fallen people they try to
amass all the evidence they can so that
a person may be just guilty Beyond
Reasonable Doubt well if God is Not
beyond the Reasonable Doubt with God
there's no doubt at all
look at all the evidence
microscopically recorded
God doesn't do that because he wants to
hurt you he does that so his Justice can
be Vindicated not because he's
vindictive his justice has to be
Vindicated because angels are watching
the unfollen worlds are watching we have
to understand that only father son Holy
Ghost know everything the angels Don't
unfollow rules don't and we surely don't
and so they are watching and God has to
think of them and so he needs evidence
that will convince angels
unfallen worlds
not just human beings next question amen
next question do we determine what goes
in these books yes by certain sense yes
yeah you might commit a crime it goes
into the book so in that sense I have
determined what goes into the book yes
if I choose to do what's right that goes
into the book
so we have some measure of
responsibility God does not invent
crimes and record them against us nor
does he invent acts of righteousness no
we choose to obey or disobey on our
choices are recorded because choices
expressed through actions if I choose to
kill you I don't have to get a gun or
get a hand grenade or cut your head off
that action and that thought they are
both recorded in God's books and so yes
in that sense we determine what goes
into that book
God Alone
by the life we live we tell him what to
write if I'm a thief with a God right
Thief where he writes thief because I've
chosen to be a thief are you with me if
I choose to forgive someone who has hurt
me bought rights forgive so yeah it is
God who uh writes your information but
we live the life
we made the choices God inscribed let's
go to Second Corinthians chapter three
let's read verse three talk about God
writing second Corinthians 3 chapter
chapter 3 verse 3.
oh yeah
for as much as ye are manifestly
declared to be a pencil of Christ yes
and then if stirred by up yes
[Music]
but with the spirits of the Living God
of the heart God writes he writes how he
does it I don't know I don't need to
know I know he writes he records he
wrote the Ten Commandments he can write
in a book
amen our next question I'll repeat who
judges what is in these books and why
the judgment is made by God
you see the Judgment going on now the
presiding judge is the father are you
with me Christ is our intercessor the
presiding judge is the father now in the
Thousand Years After Christ you know the
Millennium Christ comes he takes us away
for a thousand years the judge will be
Jesus
because the judgment is not to decide
who would be saved but the degree of
punishment for those who are lost the
ultimate punishment is death but how
long you suffer before you're extinct
that that has to be decided and so the
Bible says in First Corinthians 6 verses
one to three we will judge the world we
will judge Angels this is not the
Judgment going on now the what that
judgment refers to is the Judgment of
the during the thousand years are you
following me when Jesus is the judge we
are his assistants but now the father is
the judge the angels are present and
Christ is the intercessor when that ends
Christ comes back we begin the thousand
years we now judge the wicked in the
sense we determine with Christ
the measure of suffering before they
finally blotted out this is Bible
teaching it may not be pleasant but the
most popular verse has Pleasant and
unpleasant for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish that's unpleasant but have
everlasting life that's Pleasant to
withhold unpleasant biblical information
from people is wrong
but no one needs to suffer no one needs
to wonder what is written against me we
simply need to keep our lives in the
hands of Jesus Christ
amen amen you know if you were speaking
I was thinking about the character of
God when he proclaimed his name to Moses
in Exodus chapter 34. you know we have
Jesus saying keeping Mercy for a
thousands forgiving iniquity and
transgression and sin and then he says
that by no means
yeah there's that balance he will not
clear the guilty and he will not
remember just
amen amen so we move on to our next
question which is when were our names
written in the Lamb's Book of Life and
you actually touched on the second place
yeah anyone who's made a choice for
Christ your name goes in
amen
yes so our next question we're moving
quickly along how does forgiveness
affect the content of death
uh that's why Christ died you see Christ
died that those of us who accept that
death that sacrifice can have our names
written in that book and not removed
not removed because to give the life to
Christ is to let the Life of Christ
stand in your place let me say it slowly
to give your life to Christ means
Christ's life is given to you let's look
at it again I give my life to Christ he
gives this to me and otherwise says if
you give yourself to him and accept him
as your savior sinful as your life
though of mean
for his sake you're counted righteous
Christ's character stands in place of
your character and you are accepted by
God just as if you've never sinned
this is an astonishing statement when
you give the life to Christ when your
name comes up it is the Life of Christ
that's sin
and no one whose life is in the hand of
Christ can be lost absolutely not
and so by choosing Christ our names
entered
by leaving Christ the name is removed we
leave Christ by sin not a mistake a life
of sin a choice to live contrary to thus
said the Lord and all of Genesis
Revelation can be condensed in one
statement the Ten Commandments
um
absolutely
but we won't believe that and so we
suffer
we just won't believe it
so this is so simple the devil makes it
complex
now we accept the devil's version it's
very sad very sad very sad you know Eloy
says Satan what he does he puts upon God
his own characteristics when I say puts
upon God he gives us the view God the
way he really is
and that we treat God as though God is
Satan
it's a very sad thing she also says
desire of interest when the devil
tempted Christ in the wilderness the
devil tried to tell Christ he was the
one cast out of Heaven well it was Satan
himself he tried to convince Christ he
was the one cast out of heaven
that's the way the Satan functions he
gives to God his characteristics and so
we see God as holding a high-powered
rifle waiting to shoot everyone who
makes a mistake that's how we see God
that's the way the devil is but one of
the last things God will do before he
comes is to give the world a very clear
revelation of his love and the way he
really is
next question
amen amen well before that be our final
question yes reflecting on the well God
and him picking records how can we take
record of our lives and what is the
importance of reflection in the life of
the Christian
we have to examine ourselves constantly
the carnal nature tends to view itself
as without fault without flaw a plus
when we view ourselves through the limbs
of the word of God through the lens of
the carrot of Christ then we see how far
short we have fallen so we must
constantly examine ourselves in the
light of the character of Jesus Christ
in the light of the righteousness of
Jesus Christ in the light of thus saith
the Lord in the light of the Ten
Commandments which express perfectly the
righteousness of God because the law is
as righteous as God himself as sacred as
God himself we must engage in constant
examination of ourselves
the person who doesn't is assuming I'm
fine I need no assessment of myself that
is fatal and catastrophic we must
examine ourselves daily if not hourly if
not minutely if not Moment by moment
because it only takes a moment to do
something silly that ruins your life
we have to examine ourselves in the
light of God what I hate to be
repetitious but it's necessary
constantly
that's why the Bible says be sober be
vigilante
you know you're not Vigilant while you
sleep and snore be vigilant
keep your eyes open as we say keep your
eyes peeled look at not looking at you
look at me
by the way if we looked at ourselves
where we should we'd have little time to
look at other people
powerful powerful powerful you know you
said that same text that came to mind as
you were speaking be sober be vigilant
Vigilant you know the devil is Vigilant
we need to be
yes he is you can't blame him
he is vigilant
he doesn't sleep he's an insomnia always
awake
um
but you know right now it's Children of
the light and it's time to wake up
wake up and and examine ourselves yes
you know there's a text that I'll just
read you know you quoted in the
beginning Psalm 139 the last two verses
God yes and know my heart behind me and
know my thoughts and see if they're
being any wicked way me and leave me in
the way Everlasting everyone you know
what job said in job 42
he said I had heard of thee by the
hearing of the air now I
see the uh-huh and I abhor myself
and repentance
the closer you come to Christ the more
clearly you see how undone you are
self-examination is absolutely essential
so Jesus says in Matthew 7
before trying to take the boat out of
somebody else's eye take the beam out of
yours in order to examine yourself
there's something in your eye that
prevents you from seeing clearly take
that out then you may consider trying to
take something from somebody else's eye
self-examination
and as I said earlier self-examination
is a lifelong event a process
and it gives you a little time to
examine other people
amen amen now I always think we have one
informed question it has to be on the
subject yep it is on this subject falls
out from a lot of quashi can there be
persons who are alive that have their
probation already over what's that
person's last name
Washi
q-u-a-s-h-i-e that's right OST sounds
Trinidadian anyway
the father is from Trinidad
I'll defeat you know so much praise the
Lord no that's a wild guess okay God
bless the question read the question
again
can there be persons who are
at the probation already oh yes and they
don't know it yes last day offense I
think it's paid no no uh pictures of
prophet page 140 paragraph one I think
it is every day or every hour the
probation of some is closing every day
some are moving beyond the point of a
safety I think I'm not quoting precisely
yes it can happen yes
but it doesn't happen until God is
giving you ample opportunity to do what
is right there are people walking around
attending church their probation has
closed
now radio Foundation closes you lose all
interests and spiritual things you keep
up the habit of church but you really
have little interest in true deep
spirituality now if you're constantly
bothered by the life you live your
probation is not closed because the
spirit is still working on you so for
someone who listens to me and you're
panicking right now if you're troubled
by the life you live if you're bothered
by the fact you no longer go to church
you're living a life that dissolutes it
is the spirit of God still wrestling
with you
and you have not someone whose probation
is closed does not have those feelings
but yes you can be alive and your
probation close Souls probation Clause
he sat on the throne for several years
first Samuel 16 14 the spirit of God
less Saul
but he sat on the throne for a while
while he was trying to kill David seven
years actually
any other question on this subject no no
other questions on the topic of the
skeet we expect great gratitude to you
for your dedication and commitment to
this ministry and the cause I we are
praying God continued it really is yes
amen we are praying God continued
richest bounties upon your life the life
of your wife and your ministry at large
may he continue to be larger territory
and restore your strength I don't know
how you do it overseas you know service
the Lord
amen amen the Lord gives you strength he
really does he really does
uh but remember to pray for the Spain
Ministry that I'm going on well it's a
very interesting situation the families
that the family that invited me is one
of several families they love God
they observed the Sabbath they left
Ellen White's they're not 70 Adventists
wow they're not but the loveliest people
you can find so I look forward very much
the fellowship being with them I'll be
there the 27th of October the 1st but it
shows how God God knows how to lead
people to the truth he really does so
I'm not going to do anything and get in
the way of God's spirit I'm going to be
a part of something God is doing
teach the words and then let God do what
he started I don't want to stick my nose
in it and cause trouble I let God
continue what he's doing as he gives me
additional messages to give to those
lovely families I look forward very much
to seeing them I leave on Monday I'll be
back October the 3rd
oh wow look at that praise the Lord
someone just put in the chat Mark cook
who's watching from Trinidad and Tobago
October 3rd is my birthday oh tell him
happy birthday
well happy birthday brother cook and
Elvis Eaton will surely praying for that
Ministry thank you thank you thank you
let me see how the holy spirit is
reaching people yes yes he is reaching
people the gospel is going forth praise
the Lord praise the lord well thank you
so much all right my pleasure I will not
keep you any longer I'll let you eat
some lunch
thank you so much thank you so much
you're welcome God bless you super
abundantly my lovely sister God bless
all those who listen all I can say to
you is obedience
guarantees Ultimate Survival let me say
it again obedience to God
guarantees Ultimate Survival this life
and in the life to come so may the Lord
bless you keep you Faithful may the Lord
doubly bless your children Dr Nisha may
God bless your studies and may your
patience whomever you interact with see
Christ in you
healing page 391 paragraph one or two
Satan is the originator of disease and
any attempt to heal disease is an
interaction is a fight against it
is the originator of disease and any
attempt to cure disease is to enter into
a better statement so you need Christ
okay thank you so much
saying happy birthday in advance
September 25th
that's my birthday September yeah she's
telling you yeah wow look at that he's
telling you happy birthday in advance
happy birthday all this week thank you
thank you thank you okay amen amen thank
God for life thank God for Life indeed
indeed well I run away now I have to
prepare for two more presentations
wow may God be with you all this
obviously we wish you God's seed God
thank you God bless bye take care thank
you so much okay you're welcome you're
welcome
amen what a blessed privilege to have
had Elvis keep on this afternoon and I
extend gratitude to all of you that are
joining on YouTube and as well as Zoom
it's so good to see sister a lot of
quashi she's asked questions on this
program before sister Beverly Henry who
actually joins first we have Pastor
Stephen bino my beloved mother whose
conflict prayers I lean upon with the
Eugene Charles Dr Tara Long and our dear
sister rossan Palmer who will be doing
our closing prayer and those of you on
YouTube and other platforms it's so good
to see Juan's sister
Henderson is virtuous woman we are so
blessed by your ministry and for your
kindness to us and to God's people for
the cook Sunday law Watcher CB sister
Donna Rodney who my lovingly called
sister Loretta and sister Camille
grahamway my mouse is freezing up here
on me
so I'm unable to scroll down to see
those of you that are
also here
let me see how I can use this
nah I'm sorry friends my mouth is frozen
but for those of you watching on the
various platforms whether that be
Facebook Twitter I'm sure it's just
Amanda you're either watching or
watching the replay thank you all for
your prayerful support and if there's
one thing that we take away today
well at least two things number one God
is just and in order to vindicate his
name and his character he keeps a
meticulous record of the things that we
do not for our detriment
but even for our justification for our
righteousness and our Saints vacation
and point number two we are thus
behooved to reflect on our lives to do
Moments by moments self-examination to
see how we are aligned or aligning
ourselves with the law of God the
standard by which we will be judged
Okay so
we will now be blessed by us piece of
special music you know we were told
before to be sober and Vigilant because
our adversary the devil has a roaring
lion walked up about seeking whom he may
devour well brother Joseph vigilance
has sent in a piece of meditation namely
the song that name
uh for us to be blessed
so I will play that piece
[Music]
oh
very the name that is so precious
[Music]
because of him
I am made free that name is Jesus
for how I love him the one who gave his
life for me
because of love
so
unconditional
I will have life
eternally
[Music]
thank you
just lived speaks
onto my storm clouds this name is
[Music]
so near that name is us oh how I love
him the one who gave his life
for me because
[Music]
increase
that name
[Applause]
is
someday
I'll leave this Earthly dwelling
and finally finally I'll see the face of
my
I'll see him and praise His name
forever more
the one who gave
his life for me his life for me
because of love so
unconditional I will have life
eternally
praise
Darkness
[Laughter]
amen praise that name Hallelujah yes
amen sister with son praise that name
yes sister quashi and I miss the
messages in the chat earlier I'll relay
them to Elder skeet my sister Beverly
was wishing you continue happy birthday
continued blessings thank you sister
Beverly for your kind words and brothers
and sisters
the powerful thing about the name of
Christ is not just j-e-s-u-s
but it is his character his Spirit his
life in that name may we have our lives
hid with Christ in God so that as our
lives are abandoned we will not be seen
but Jesus his name his character his
life his Spirit his power will be seen
amen virtuous woman praise the Lord he
is worthy to be praised and thank you
sister Angela Buckner for joining your
continued support and love is greatly
appreciated and yes take courage lr73
when you give your life to Jesus Christ
you are covered you are covered and so
good to see you the protest and
so we will now transition to our closing
prayer before I do that please stay
tuned for October 28th I'm planning
we're planning by God's grace something
special why is that out yet but trust me
there is something special in mind so
stay tuned keep October 28th it may not
necessarily be two o'clock P.M Eastern
Standard Time we're working that out but
keep Sabbath October 28th in mind
without further Ado I'm going to invite
Mr bassan Palmer my dear sister and
friend to do our clothing prayer
dear heavenly father we give you thanks
for the privilege to have come before
you today we ask that you may allow the
message that we heard today to sing deep
into our hearts God please continue to
anoint elderski and his ministry help
him to continue to be steward-filled and
on fire for you help us all to in our
own spheres be the powerhouses if you'd
like us to be and we give you thanks for
doing that thank you for that point of
your Holy Spirit in Jesus name amen amen
amen once again many thanks praise God
for what he has done this afternoon I
just want to say thank you to brother
and sister Archie and Pat Elder I could
forget his name Byron I believe for
helping me with this setup I'm not home
I'm at South Ozone Park church but they
gave me a laptop so that I can post this
live stream and he thinks my mom for her
headphones which I'm using and all of
you the participants from the song from
Elder Joseph vigilance the prayer from
Sister wasam Plummer and those of you
that lovingly support with your presence
and by sharing the word thank you from
the bottom of my heart and may we remain
faithful as we not only look forward to
but hasten the return of our Lord and
savior
so until next time take care and God
bless